We're on problem 39.
And it says which ordered pairs
the vertex of f of x is
equal to x squared
plus 6x plus 5?
Now, finding vertexes of
parabolas, there's a formula,
and negative b over 2a, but you
might forget that when you
turn 30 years old.
The whole goal of this isn't
just to pass an algebra exam.
It's to learn algebra.
Then when you learn calculus,
you'll learn actually a much
easier way to figure out minimum
and maximum points.
But there's actually an
intuitive way of doing it in
algebra as well.
What we have to do is just
write this in that form.
If we could write this function
in the form like
this, f of x is equal to A,
times x plus or minus
something, I don't know,
b, squared, plus C.
Then we know the vertex happens
when x is equal to b.
Because if you look at this form
of a parabola-- and you
can write any of these in this
form-- then you say OK, this
term right here is always
going to be positive.
So the minimum point of this
parabola is when this term is
equal to 0.
Then the minimum point of this
term happens when x is equal
to b, when this term
is equal to 0.
So the vertex becomes
xb comma C.
So let's do that with this.
You could memorize it.
It ends up being minus
b over 2A.
But let's just actually solve
it, because I want you to have
the intuition.
f of x is equal to x squared
plus 6x, plus 5.
I wrote a gap there for a
reason, because we're
essentially going to
complete a square.
We want to turn this x squared
plus 6x, plus something, into
a perfect square.
Hopefully you have
some practice
completing the square.
What number is 1/2 of 6?
Because when we square it, if
we do x plus a squared, that
equals what? x squared plus
2ax plus a squared.
So if we map that to that,
x squared is x squared.
2ax is equal to 6.
So a would be equal to 3.
And if a is equal to 3, a
squared would be equal to 9.
You can't just add a 9 to one
side of the equation.
You either have to do it to both
sides, or you have to do
something to offset that.
So if we added a 9 here, let's
just subtract a 9 as well.
So then we get x squared plus
6x, plus 9, plus 5, minus 9.
So this right here, this part of
it, that's equal to x plus
3, squared.
And then this part, 5
minus 9, minus 4.
There, we got it into our
format that we needed.
So when does this function
achieve a minimum point?
Well, it achieves a minimum
point when this part is equal
to 0, or when x is
equal to minus 3.
When x is equal to minus
3, this is 0.
So f of x is going to
be equal to minus 4.
So that's the vertex,
and that's choice A.
You could have done
minus b over 2A.
You'd get minus 12 over
2-- no minus 6 over 2,
which is minus 3.
That's something you
could memorize.
But it's better, I think,
to have the intuition.
Problem 40.
The graph of x over 2, squared,
minus y over 2,
squared equals 1
is a hyperbola.
That makes sense.
This is y over 3. x over 2,
squared, minus y over 3,
squared is equal to 1.
If this is a plus, we would
have an ellipse.
Fair enough.
Which set of equations
represents the asymptotes of
the hyperbola's graph?
Once again, there's some
equations that people memorize
and formulas people memorize,
but you can actually have an
intuition on this.
So let's think about what
happens as x approaches
positive or negative infinity.
Because that's what we care
about as an asymptote, right?
What does the graph approach
when we get to really, really
large values of x, and
it turns out, really
large values of y?
So let's just rearrange
this a little bit.
Let's put y on the other side.
Let's square this.
So this is x squared over 4.
Let me keep it actually
in that format.
Let's keep that as x over 2,
squared is equal to 1, plus y
over 3, squared.
Let's subtract 1 from
both sides.
So you get x over 2, squared,
minus 1 is equal
to y over 3, squared.
And now, let's multiply both
sides by 3 squared.
Let's multiply both
sides by 9.
Let's do that.
Actually, to simplify this,
let me rewrite this.
I wanted to keep in that form.
That's the same thing as x
squared over 4, minus 1, is
equal to y squared over 9.
Multiply both sides by 9.
I'm going to switch the sides
so we get y here.
So you get y squared is
equal to 9 over 4 x
squared, minus 9.
All right, and that's about as
far as we can get just with
straight up algebra.
When we think about asymptotes,
those are points
that the graphs will never reach
but it'll get close to.
So we have to think about what
happens with x gets really
large and correspondingly
y gets really large.
Well, as x gets really large, so
as x approaches infinity--
and you'll learn this is
precalculus and calculus,
these are limits, but it's
really a very intuitive
concept-- as x gets really
large, this minus 9 doesn't
matter much.
This term starts
to dominate it.
These terms matter a lot
more than this minus 9.
So as x approaches infinity, y
squared is approximately equal
to 9/4 x squared.
Now we could take the square
root of both sides of this.
So you get y is approximately
equal to plus or minus 3/2 x.
Those are the actual asymptotes,
y equals 3/2 x and
y is equal to minus 3/2 x.
That's actually choice A.
I won't go into the actual
instruction of how you would
think about graphing.
Actually, why not?
Why don't we just do that.
We know what the
asymptotes are.
Let's actually think about
how you would graph this.
So if you were to draw the--
it's all about learning, not
just about assessing-- that's
the x- and y-axis.
And they tell us their
asymptotes, 3/2 x
and minus 3/2 x.
So 3/2 x, the slope
of 3/2 is 1.5.
So it's a slope that will look
something like-- let me get
the line tool out-- so x might
look like, so plus 3/2 x would
look something like that.
Minus 3/2 x would be something
like that.
Now we have to figure out does
this hyperbola go from there
and there, or does it go
from here and here?
There were just say, OK, when y
is equal to 0 we get x over
2 is equal to plus or minus 1.
You actually get x
would be there.
So you know that this thing
has x-intercepts.
You can set y is equal to 0.
You can't set x is equal to 0.
If you get x is equal to 0, then
you get minus y squared
is equal to something.
You get y squared is equal
to negative 1.
You get some imaginary
solution.
So you know that it
has x-intercepts.
You know that these are
the asymptotes.
So if you want to draw the
graph, it would look
something like that.
I know that's not a great
drawing, but hopefully it
serves the purpose.
Anyway, the choice was A.
And hopefully you learned a
little bit about asymptotes.
Next problem, 41.
Which of the following
represents a hyperbola?
Let me copy those.
No, which of the following
represents a parabola, they
want to know.
That's too small.
I don't think you
can see that.
I'll get a bigger
version of it.
All right, that's the
bigger version.
There you go.
Which of these represents
a parabola?
Well, we could just
go one by one.
This is a circle.
That's a circle.
Then you could graph
if you like.
This is an ellipse, where you
just kind of weight the y's
and the x squareds.
This is an ellipse.
If this was a negative, this
would be a hyperbola, ellipse.
This one is a hyperbola
because you have
this negative here.
This one might not look like
a traditional parabola,
but it really is.
Because if I were to divide both
sides of this by 4p, I'd
get x is equal to 1 over
4p times y squared.
So it's a sideways parabola.
It looks something like this.
If that's the x- and y-axis,
the graph will look
something like this.
It's going to be a sideways
parabola.
But it's a parabola
nonetheless.
So the choice is C.
We have time for at least
one more, problem 42.
They give the following
equation.
Let me paste it here.
All right, and they say what
is the standard form of the
equation of the conic
section above?
And essentially they want us
to complete the square with
the x's and the y's so we get
that x minus something
squared, over some m plus or
minus y, minus something
squared, over some constant.
So let's do that.
So let's group the x and the y
terms. So you get 4x squared,
minus 16x, plus something.
That's how we're going to
complete the square.
Then you get plus minus
5y squared.
Let me just minus, and I'll
do plus 5y squared.
We have a minus here, so
it becomes plus 30y.
And then out here you have
a minus 9 is equal to 0.
Just to simplify it, let's
factor a 4 out of this part.
So you get 4 times x squared,
minus 4x, plus something,
minus-- let's factor a 5 out--
5, times y squared, plus 6y,
probably plus something-- and
let's add the 9 to both
sides-- is equal to 9.
All right, so let's
think about it.
If we wanted to complete the
square here, what do we put
here to make this a
perfect square?
If this was a plus 4,
then this would
be x minus 2 squared.
So we're adding a 4 here.
But we're really adding
a 4 times a 4.
We're really adding a 16
if you think about it.
If I were to redistribute
this, I just added 16.
So if I add 16 to one side of
the equation, I have to add 16
to the other side
of the equation.
So I'll add 16 there.
To make this a perfect square,
let's see, 1/2 of 6 is 3, so 3
squared is 9.
But I'm really adding
a 5 times a 9.
I could redistribute the 5.
I really added a 45.
Oh, no, no, no.
I added a minus 5 times 9.
I caught myself.
So I'm really subtracting
45 from that side.
So I have to subtract
And so this simplifies to 4
times x minus 2 squared--
right, that's x minus two
squared-- minus 5 times-- this
is y plus 3 squared-- is equal
to-- let's see, 9 plus 16 is
25, 25 minus 45.
Let's see, have I made
a mistake someplace?
25 minus 45, no, that's right.
25 minus 45 is minus 20.
And now we can divide both sides
by minus 20, if I did
this correctly.
We'll divide both sides
by minus 20.
So you get x minus 2 squared.
What's 4 divided by minus 20?
It's minus 1/5.
Let me just do that.
So 4 over minus 20, minus 5,
times y plus 3 squared, over
minus 20 is equal to 1.
So this is equal to, let's see
this becomes a positive, and
this one becomes a negative.
So let's put this one first. So
5 over 20 is the same thing
as y plus 3 squared, over
4-- right, that's this
one-- plus, no, sorry.
We have a minus.
Minus-- and this becomes 1/5--
x minus 2 squared, over 5.
That is equal to 1.
We haven't made a careless
mistake.
That is choice B.
See you in the the next video.